this weekend families in the downtown
area were invited to make use of some
free resources available so children can
have a successful school year all thanks
to business network international and
the local non-profit faith in humanity
reports
every student deserves the chance to
walk in on the first day of school
feeling confident and sunday's event
made sure of that i know these moms and
dads are working as hard as they can
possibly work
so i'm grateful that we can give back to
them as well hairdresser lauren thomas
is just one of the hundreds of business
owners helping students who are homeless
or less fortunate to have a fresh start
for their first day with free haircuts
clothes and supply my heart hurts a
little bit the need for free resources
was evident with the hundreds of
families that gathered near east
charleston and chapman drive
mom crystal krauss waited in line for
two hours with her three kids we were
homeless i don't have a job so it's kind
of hard getting my kids needs met so
with programs like this it helps my kids
to get you know the stuff they need for
their first day of school and
helped me get back on my feet a little
bit business network international helps
provide funding for local businesses and
charities to give back they have a
future and however small and however
lost they feel however unfortunate they
are we do have a chance to make them
into something really really good and it
all starts with feeling and looking your
best how do you like your haircut i love
it what time are you waking up tomorrow
seven o'clock are you ready yeah
victoria saha live local now
the event brought in more than 300
families business networking
international says they hope to do more
events like this and target different
areas